[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today what's
going
on hi uh yeah I just kind of wanted to
run by uh my car purchase with you and
see if I made an irresponsible purchase
I don't think so oh this is fun Matt
this is fun pop quiz time we'll tell you
true or false yeah if you finan it I'm
probably going to say true but let's
let's talk about it what's going on so I
needed a car because I had a car that I
ran into the ground I put like 275,000
miles on it and it needed a $5,000
repair but the car was only worth maybe
a thousand bucks at this point and so I
got rid of it and I decided to get
something new reliable that um I work a
lot and I just the unforeseen not having
a car just doesn't work for me there's a
lot of caveats here already but keep
going yeah yeah sure and um so I decided
to get what I wanted and it wasn't too
expensive but from where I come from
like I for a long time of my life I was
a drug addict with nothing right and
yeah I was never used to having any
money and now um you know I waited
tables to put myself back through school
and ended up in a career thank you thank
you I'm seven and a half years clean and
so it's great congratulations thank you
thank you and so I decided to you know
treat myself and and get the car that I
wanted and so what' you spend still kind
of I spent um after down payment the
amount financed is 26,000 okay how much
do you make a
year um after taxes I take home about 96
Grand okay good for you what are you
doing now workwise thank you I'm a pipe
fitter okay good for you well Matt
you're impressive in general I think the
idea of beating addiction or being in a
certain lifestyle and then completely
by your own mission just completely
changing your life around is the is the
biggest thing ever right car payment or
not like people like you that do that
it's it's remarkable absolutely
remarkable and I find that you know with
a story like that or even we talked to
people we talked to a lady yesterday who
she battled cancer and she got over it
but she went and purchased you know a
new car she wanted for the S like
there's a there's so many emotions tied
to money and there's this level of
Celebration or this level of like I
finally like like I I don't want to
drive the crappy car anymore like I want
a break give me a break life give me a
break like it's been tough right so so
that emotion is is very real it doesn't
um eliminate the mathematical side of it
right regardless of why we purchased it
there is still debt in the picture so um
so yeah I would it's not an insane
number compared to your income like if
you were making $30,000 I'd have to tell
you you have to sell this but you could
probably pay it off pretty quickly do
you have any other debt at all besides
just the
car um on my house okay I purchased the
house and um I have about 880,000 left
on the house I'm chunking it away as
fast as I can yeah good for you so do
you have any savings right
now um liquid cash about 12,000 okay
awesome um yes go go ahead I have a I
have a 401 k um where my company puts in
5% of my income and then I put in um 15%
on top of that okay and the the eight
grand a month is after I put in the 15%
as well like that's just my take home
okay awesome um good for you and I'm
Union so I don't have to pay for healthc
care I don't have to pay for any of that
like that take home is my money I just
get to do it as I please awesome that's
great okay so what I would do Matt is I
honestly in your position I would pause
that 15% going into retirement for now
get some of that cash back in your
paycheck I would take 11,000 you're not
going to like this but I would take
11,000 of that savings bring it down to
$1,000 I would throw
11,000 at this car and at that point
you're going to have $155,000 left in
car debt and I would do whatever I could
between now
and April give yourself a timeline kind
of map it out and say if I work extra if
I work nights if I drive Uber if I like
go crazy for about four to five months
knock the rest of this out and then save
up more on top of that ,000 to a 3 to
six months um of expenses in an
emergency fund and you could do that by
fall of next year and then press play
again back to your retirement then and
be funding your 401k so you're really
just going to pause it I'm making up
timelines you would have to run your own
numbers but you know for a year maybe
pausing retirement to get this debt paid
off to get an emergency fund back into
place and and then you're well on your
way M and then your mortgage is 80 grand
and if you start yeah putting more
towards that even you're G going to pay
that off really quick and Matt you're
gonna it's going to be a a whole new
world for you but I would I would I
would do what I could to pay that that
car debt off um as soon as
possible yeah that's what I'm thinking I
I think I could get it paid off
comfortably in the next I mean if I take
that money out and I put it towards a
car probably six months yeah I get it
paid off easily yep for sure I know and
then I would say too don't do it
comfortably maybe it's really
uncomfortable and you do it in four
months right like you you do some stuff
that you really do sacrifice and just do
it are you are you single
married um I have a girlfriend but no uh
like Financial SI to anyone else yeah
that's great so I think now I'm like
this is the time it's the time just to
do it because the other power mat and
and go to Ramsey solutions.com and look
up our investing calculator I think this
is always fun especially with a car
payment cuz it's a depreciating asset uh
throw your car payment in an investment
calculator and just say from now till
I'm 65 like how much could that be at
retirement I mean because Matt you're
you're well on your way to becoming what
what we always say is baby steps
millionaire yeah um so it's powerful and
and who you are Matt and your the story
you told us at the beginning I'm like oh
yeah this is like this is a piece of
cake if you can get over if you can
tackle an addiction like this car thing
oh yeah this is nothing I mean this is
this is four months of Lifestyle
sacrifice and some extra you know work
that's right on top of your job like you
can do this but I think that I'm I'm
pretty used to being uncomfortable yeah
yeah you would have to be I'm looking at
these numbers and how you turn turned
your life around and that's just
unbelievable to me how old are
you um I'm 29 29 okay way to good for
you that's awesome well thanks for
calling Matt uh I hope that gives you
some Direction but again uh that's a
real thing Jade of that's what we always
say money is never just about money
there's there's so much more underneath
that is kind of churning that causes us
yeah to do the things we do with money I
wrote a book called know yourself know
your money all about this because I'm
like whether it's your childhood how you
were brought up um the life you're
living today your fears your dreams your
natural god-given personality and
tendency uh envirment I mean all of this
shapes why we do the things we do with
money and so for him I'm like yeah the
the idea that you know you you climb
this Mass massive Mountain personally um
and what he was dealing with you know
there there is that feeling of like goly
I I deserve a good car like this is what
I've done and there I ow it to myself
yeah and I get that right I you don't
want to drive the crappy car but also
that doesn't eliminate the financial
ramifications right that come with it so
being debt free gives um freedom in
another part of your life that's right
in that money side and luckily he didn't
go too far off the rails like I was
expecting him to be like I spent $50,000
and bought a you know an Escalade so he
he kept it somewhat reasonable luckily
he'll be able to pay it off in the next
year um if it was more than that though
we might have given him different
different advice but yep I know selling
the car and and for all you listening it
um and this isn't to pick on Matt by any
means but just in general the car debt
for me Jade is the one that hurts the
most when people call in because I'm
like okay credit cards you know some
people are doing it to keep up with
their bill like you you you you can to a
point be like okay there the student
loan thing we all know why you know
people fall into that trap all the time
uh there's certain parts that you can
kind of see but it's the the C Deb one
it always gets me because of the amount
people pay in payments we actually did a
video together or saw a video together
people and it was like $1,200 a month in
one car that's going to car payments and
you're just thinking no and I'm not even
overly math nerd but I'm like you invest
that instead let that work for you than
the car dealership or the bank like it's
it's crazy so it's great the car payment
it what it's what keeps the middle class
middle and it's what keeps you broke so
make sure to get those cars paid off
it's not worth it to pay payment the
rest of your life when you could use
that payment to become a millionaire